[Music]
my family i would say tim went through a
very difficult 10-year period a period
of intense suffering
and
and yet that suffering became the place
where we learned to do the work and go
inward and start to understand how
healing processes work and so
i've gotten to the place now where i've
i fondly look back on those 10 years of
initiation you know university of
suffering
but it began for me
when my grandmother died
my father who had he had taken the
londolozi model of care of land care of
wildlife care of people and he had
launched it to 30 other operations
around southern africa
which mandela had asked him to do and so
he had there'd been this big sort of
expansion and then in a classic kind of
change of founders trap he got fired
from that
and then very soon into that south
africa was going through a very very
difficult time
and one night we were in johannesburg
and this was
post elections but it was still it was
still
you know very
the country was still really finding its
feet and there was a ton of violent
crime still happening
and
i was yeah as i said i was 18 years old
and i i woke up and my sister was
shaking me
and immediately as i sat up i had a gun
pushed into my face
and
the home that we were staying in in
johannesburg and that occasion had been
invaded
and i just felt
you know the adrenaline pumped through
my system and
all of my work
as in healing spaces later and i know
that you're involved in psychedelic
assisted therapy has been to try and get
a cap on the scope of
where my body goes when it gets a mild
trauma because i woke up into my worst
nightmare and i look to my left and my
mother's tied up
on the floor and my sister's tied up
and
i know kind of stories of how these
things go the violence
the potential danger to women
and it was just like absolute redline
fear
and just to see the woman in my life my
family like that and
so just shocking and then
realizing that you know i know
i can read animals i can't quite read
people like i mean i can't quite read
them it's they don't they're they're not
as honest as animals you know so i just
don't know where this is gonna go and
i'm sitting in this tension
and eventually they took me
uh they took me outside
and these
these guys who had broken into the house
and they said to me we're going to kill
you
and
so they pulled me outside and they put a
gun to my head
and they said this is they basically
said now we're going to kill you
and
you know the fear was so intense and
then i remember looking up the barrel at
the man who was holding the gun to my
head and we looked into each other's
eyes
and in that moment something happened
which
i can't say what happened you might call
it the peace of god that path is
understanding but
i think it was too big for my ego
structure to hold and it and it
collapsed
and as i looked at him all fear left me
and
all concern for my own bodily safety
left me and i just felt a profound human
connection with him
and as that happened and there were
three of these guys standing around me
as as that moment happened it was kind
of this
this weird
the only way i can describe it is a kind
of a weirdness came over everyone it was
as if everyone had become glimmered
and they put the guns down and everyone
just stood there confused
and i walked back inside totally un
uh and accosted in any way and i got the
car keys and i walked back out and i
gave them the car keys and i said get in
that car and leave
and they did
and it was just
immensely bizarre and
and for years i lived with trying to
work out both the terror that i felt and
the the fear that had flooded me but
also trying to integrate like whatever
had happened in that moment
um and i'm not sure that i i fully
understand it but
you know i i felt like i glimpsed
through the most terrifying situation i
i glimpsed something
and so that was that was a very very
sort of that was the first freezing
experience that i had
it was terrifying
and then on the heels of that
and i think sometimes of jung's um
jung's uh description of like
what is unconscious will be made
conscious uh it will manifest into your
life until you become more conscious
about what you're carrying
a couple of weeks after that
literally in the same year
myself and a friend
myself and some friends and another
tracker called soliantlongo we went down
to the river on the reserve
and it was an extremely hot day and we
left the people who we were guiding
sort of sitting under a tree and we
began to walk upstream in the river
and sully stayed on the bank and i was
actually walking in the water and the
water was knee-deep
running over sand and you could see
quite clearly
and then there was a place up ahead
where a tree had fallen over and its
branches were in the water
and it was kind of shadowy
and i when i think of it now i think if
it had been a horror movie you know
people in the audience would have
started saying don't go near the shadowy
place
um and of course as i walked past the
shadowy place i actually sat down just
on the edge of those shadows and my
perception was that the water was too
shallow for crocodiles but of course the
crocodile was in the hole
and
the first thing that you notice when a
crocodile grabs you is just the ferocity
and the pressure of the bite i just felt
it slam onto my right leg and it tries
to pull me into the deep section of the
water i throw my arm up and i grab a
branch and it starts to shake me and i
see a slick of blood appear in the water
and then it gets washed downstream
while the crocodile is shaking me i see
sully who's on the bank he sees me and
he sees that i'm in trouble
and he immediately starts making his way
towards me
sully is also a shanghain man grew up
hunting and gathering
the croc goes to bite me a second time
and i kicked and by the grace of god my
foot went down its throat and it spat me
out
and i pulled myself up into the branches
of the tree
and i have this memory of almost being
non-local watching myself pull myself
up into the branches of the tree
i got up into the branches and i
remember looking over my shoulder and my
leg from the knee down is just
absolutely mangled torn to pieces and
meat hanging off
i made a pact with myself in that moment
i'd never look at that again
and i made my way through the branches
and i fell onto the bank
and i knew that i was extremely
vulnerable on the bank crocodile's it's
an elite predator if it thinks it can
get you and i was on the bank against
the water it's going to grab me again
at that point sully coming from the
other bank arrives at the deep section
of the channel
he's seen me come out of the water he's
seen that my leg is mangled and he knows
that in the deep channel of water
between him and i is a crocodile
and i can tell you that man didn't slow
down not for one second he plunged into
the water he waded into almost over his
hips and he got to me on the bank and he
grabbed me put me on his shoulder and he
carried me up onto the bank he took his
shirt off he wrapped it around my leg
we were able to call the folks who were
with us and calm them down radio a plane
that was flying over and i was able to
get medivacked out and
and we were able to stop the bleeding so
that i was i survived
so you know those two experiences were
very alive in me
and maybe this is a side point and and
then i'll slow down for a while but uh
you know in the in the months after that
i sat many many times with sully
and i said to him sorry
you know why why did you come in the
water
and he would look at me with disdain and
he'd say um
he said my brother you're in trouble i'm
in trouble
and at first i thought it was some kind
of like you know platitude he was
playing down his actions
but as time went on i really understood
and i came to see that in the way that
sully grew up he grew up in a much more
collective consciousness he grew up with
his tribe he grew up hunting and
gathering he grew up in nature
and he lived in a much more
interconnected way
than
than any of us live his in fact his
whole psyche was not formed around
individuality
his psyche was formed around a wee
consciousness you and me together a
collective consciousness and to him it
was fundamental if i was in trouble he
was in trouble and so he did not see it
as any kind of heroic action he just saw
it as the most obvious natural thing to
do and and that really that moved me and
that and that taught me a lot
you